I'm pleased to know that
our colleagues at MIT
are reaching out to
people all over the world
to engage them in this important
discussion about the future
of work.
We are launching our own
future of work initiative
here at the ILO.
And this course will fit very
well with our initiative.
Look, I think that our
future of work initiative
responds to two
essential things.
One's got to do with need.
One's got to do
with opportunity.
The need comes from
the fact, and we're all
conscious of this in
our everyday lives,
that there is massive
change taking place
in the world of work,
transformative change at a pace
and at a depth that
we don't really
have experience of in the past.
So we think that
we need to study
these big changes to understand
them better as a way of working
out what we should do about
them in order to make sure
that the world of work
responds to the ILO's
ideas of social justice
fairness of work.
And then there is
the opportunity.
And the opportunity
comes from the fact
that in three years
time, in 2019, the ILO
will celebrate its 100th
birthday, its centenary.
So what better opportunity--
they don't come round
that frequently--
what better
opportunity than that
to have this in depth
reflection about the direction
that the world of work is taking
and what we can do to shape it,
to move it, towards these
ideals of social justice.
We are proposing
to amend the states
that they structure their
national dialogues around four
conversations.
And very quickly, one is to
do with work and society.
Sounds a bit
philosophical, but I
think there are some really
deep questions out there
about what work means to
each and every one of us
in terms of, not only
of earning our living,
but also of self-realization,
of what our lives mean,
and how we want to
proceed with them.
Secondly, and it's a most
frequently asked question
that I at least get
about the future
is decent work of tomorrow,
the decent jobs of tomorrow.
Where are those
jobs coming from?
We're having to create 40
million jobs every year
just to absorb the new people
coming onto the labor markets.
And frankly, we're not able
to do it at the moment.
So we have to be able to discuss
the nature and the origin
of work in the future.
The third item is about the
organization, the organization
of work in production.
We're seeing the digital
economy take off.
We're seeing the way that
the internet is mediating
work in entirely new ways.
Maybe, the enterprise
is going to look
very different in the future
from what it looks like today.
We're seeing the fragmentation
and globalization
of production systems
in global supply chains.
We need to understand what
the full implications are
of this new organization and
global division of labor.
And the fourth point-- and
this is the culminating point
of the whole thing.
We have to say, well,
what are the consequences
of these changes for the ILO's
mandate for social justice?
How can we shape, manage
all of these changes,
so that we keep the world
moving in this direction
of social justice?
So let me end by
encouraging everyone
to join us in using the ideas
and the information presented
in this course to improve
the future of work
for people all around the world.